financial issue has kept melvin gordon
out of la for the entire season and you
know chris i i've written about this we
haven't talked about it much this is
like the holdout nobody gives a crap
about isn't it weird you have a running
back who's good not great who is denying
his services to his team he's missed
three regular season games game checks
of nearly 330 thousand dollars and uh
you know people are confused about when
he has to come back i want to address
this because
it's
it's clear where the authority comes
from that applies to when he needs to
come back it's not clear exactly when he
should come back to be in the best
possible standing but this all comes
from and we've mentioned this before the
joey galloway grievance from 2000 when
he was playing for the seattle seahawks
and the end result was joey galloway was
on the seahawks roster for eight games
that year the seahawks position was if
you hold out for even one regular season
game you don't get credit for that year
of your contract that's what this is all
about now for melvin gordon he's got his
four years of credit for free agency he
needs credit for his last year of his
rookie contract so the joey galloway
groovin says if you're there for eight
games you're good to go you could read
that grievance and the the the written
opinion that that applies the reasoning
and goes through the cba and the player
contract etc you could read that as
saying that he only has to be on the
roster for one game that's a very
aggressive reading of it i think the
safest thing for melvin gordon is to be
on the roster for eight games which
means being there long enough to get
through a three-week roster exemption if
the chargers use it which means chris
right showing up between week five
against the broncos and week six against
the steelers to me that's the window to
watch and it's coming up very quickly
and people are going to be surprised if
he shows up that early because people
are saying oh he doesn't have to show up
until week 10. oh he doesn't have to
show up until the final 30 days of the
season i think the safest course for him
is to show up the day after the broncos
game week five and be ready to go or be
on the roster exempt list for week six
against the steelers i feel like that's
the end game and it's gonna be here
before we know it yeah i i mean i think
you're right uh i would like to see him
be there at some point between week five
and week six because you're right if he
goes there week nine week ten tries to
do that they could a little you know
you're not in football shape or you
didn't pass the physical yet or they
could they could pull a lot of
shenanigans to say you're not on the
roster quite yet and then they can come
back to screw you and they might do that
because they might be pissed off and the
fact that melvin gordon is holding out
and really has no leverage in the
situation anyways and they probably feel
like they're in a window of being a good
team and he's messing that up chris it's
business yeah if if you can make the
argument that you still hold his
contract for another year then you can
trade him and you get you get something
in return in 2020 in advance of the
draft instead of letting him leave in
free agency and get a supplemental draft
pick a year later so there is value to
the franchise there's value to all teams
this is a management council thing hey
the guy was only on the roster for three
games that doesn't fit within joey
galloway if you're only on the roster
for three games your contract tolls and
the team still holds your rights the
next year and i know we're getting into
the weeds here legally a little bit
right but this is important because
here's the thing i have seen the
graphics when i i watch different
networks and i see what they're saying
as to when guys need to show up they're
just wrong no one has mentioned the joey
galloway grievance he works for espn for
crying out loud and they've never
mentioned the joey galloway grievance as
far as i know that is the driving force
for this melvin gordon thing and the
safest deadline for showing up is coming
up in just about what 11 or 12 days yeah
yep um i i hope he does it for his sake
listen i hope he does it for the
chargers sake the chargers miss melvin
gordon they're one and two
i have a hard time thinking melvin
gordon would have fumbled on the one
yard line going in against detroit and
maybe they win that game you know
there's been another a you know their
offense puts up numbers so we always
look at and go they're okay on offense
they don't need them but there's been a
number of big runs i've seen from austin
echol and justin jackson where i sit
there on film and go
that was a good run
but melvin gordon might have broke that
last tackle and gone the extra 40 yards
for the touchdown or he might have ran
through that arm tackle and got an extra
30 and 40 yards there so they're missing
him whether they want to
admit it or not or anything like that
it's hurting their football team he is a
special player he's just like if you
said many time he's not the cream of the
crop right now at running backs he's not
an ezekiel elliott saquon barkley
christian you know mccaffrey uh dalvin
cook right now is probably in that
conversation he's not in that category
he's that next group down but he's still
a special football player and i want to
see him get paid become a free agent and
i'm sure the chargers would like to see
him and need his help too
and that was the point you made about
ezekiel it was a great point you know
tony pollard gains four yards well
ezekiel maybe gains eight yards yeah
melvin gordon could be playing better
than these guys are performing right
that doesn't make him an elite running
back but i still think that uh he needs
to be there he will be there he needs
that year of credit under his contract
to become a free agent and then somebody
on the open and he'll find out then
we'll find out what he's worth yeah he
thinks he's worth 13 million a year
we'll find out in march yeah yep and i
don't know if he's going to be worth
that ever just because of the knee
issues and things like that but he's
worth more money than he's getting now
he's not happy with that uh i think
realistically he's probably like a 10 10
11 million a year type of guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports